- I think for the
people to realizing
that this is America's,
our moment of cultural
revolution is happening.
This is a silent revolution
in happening classrooms,
in corporate businesses,
in the media.
It's happening everywhere,
and we just don't see it.
And media is lying to us.
They are changing entire
dynamic of this country
where somehow hate
speech is a violence,
therefore, you have no
right to speak your mind.
And that's not the
definition of freedom.
People don't even understand
what it means to be American,
and they're Americans.
Like, I became a
citizen last year,
and in my citizens test,
my interviewer asking me,
"Have you ever
persecuted anybody
for their political opinion?"
If I said yes, I could
not become American.
And that's what Google does,
that's what Facebook
does, what Instagram does,
and that what used
to Twitter did.
(dramatic music)
- I'm Dave Rubin,
and joining me today
is the author of the brand
new book, "While Time Remains:
A North Korean Defector's Search
for Freedom in North America",
my friend, Yeonmi Park.
Welcome back to
the Rubin Report.
- Thank you for having me back.
- Yeonmi, last time I saw
you was in Chicago, Illinois.
You were living in
Chicago at the time,
and you opened for me
on the "Don't Burn This
Country" book tour.
We did a matinee show
at the Chicago Improv,
and I didn't tell you
you had to be funny,
but you crushed it.
You did like 10 minutes of
freedom loving standup comedy,
and you crushed it, my friend.
- Oh, thank you.
That was the most fun thing
I've ever done in my life,
so I'm very grateful.
(laughs)
- Did you ever think if you
would've gone to your life,
you know, 15 years
ago in North Korea,
that you'd be doing a
little standup comedy
in Chicago a couple years later?
- I mean, this is the thing,
like, this year was beyond
anything that I knew
about the world.
I did not even know
what standup comedy was.
And for instance, I mean,
I thought of Americans as,
you know, cold blood
reptiles monsters, right?
Never knew in my life
that I was going to
be hanging out with Americans
and, you know, make some jokes.
- Yeah, it was really
just absolutely wonderful.
One of the most
memorable ones for me.
So I don't wanna go into
your whole story again,
which you have now,
not only did you write
your first book about,
but you've obviously
told so many times over.
We'll put a link
to it down below,
so people can get a full
recap of your story.
But in essence, in a really
just unbelievable way,
you defected from North Korea,
you eventually made it
to the United States,
and really what
you're doing now,
and I think what
this book is about
is really warning people
that so many of the signs
that you saw in North Korea
are happening in the
United States right now.
Is that a fair estimation
of how this book
really shapes out?
- Yeah, absolutely.
I think most people would get
really shocked that, you know,
how dare you comparing
North Korea to America?
And, of course, I'm not
comparing the living standards
are the same.
However, the tactics that North
Korea used to control people
and brainwashing us,
was the same tactics
that I'm seeing right now
in current America.
And more and more
every single day
living in Chicago
and New York City,
I see this country
getting destroyed.
- So one of the things
that's interesting
is you've described in
the past how, you know,
basically getting
mugged on the streets,
that was in Chicago, right?
- Yeah. Mmm-hmm.
- And then these
false cries of racism
because the people who mugged
you happened to be black women
and just all of this
sort of nonsense
related to cancel culture.
But then it really got
escalated under Covid, right?
Because it wasn't
just silencing people
because someone was
calling you racist.
Then it was really government
designed silencing.
- Absolutely, I mean,
during the pandemic,
as like, everything
was canceled,
I wanted to make videos about
the plight of
North Korean women,
how they're being raped
and their organs harvest out
in China under Communist Party.
And when I talk about this
women's plight in China,
my videos get demonetized,
censored, and get shadow banned
all the social media platforms.
And I reached out
to Google like,
"Do you guys not support the
Me Too or something," right?
That's all about it.
Like, believe her,
believe what women say,
and why were they not
supporting this women's plight
of North Koreans under
China Communist Party?
And they said simply, "It
does not meet our guidelines."
And I mean, during the time,
I was raising two
years old toddler.
I'm sure now you're
being a father,
you understand how powerless
that I felt living in America.
I thought the best thing
that I've ever done
was giving my son
the US passport,
make him to born in the free of,
freedom.
But during the pandemic,
when I sent him to daycare,
his teachers would make sure
that he would wear a mask
up to here eight hours a day
to two years old,
who just barely learning
how to run and walking.
And then they were opening
strip clubs next door.
And like, bars opening.
And then they would lock
down the children's program,
but the dog parks were open.
And I was thinking
somehow the dogs have
more rights than my child
in America right now.
Like, they have
freedom to go to park
and run around under the sun,
but my son couldn't.
And I think that's
when I really realized
how powerless I was
as a individual.
I never thought that I was
going to be locked indoor.
My son would have to
put a mask like that
and couldn't go even eating
in the restaurant like that.
- It must have been
doubly jarring for you
because having come from a place
where people couldn't
say what they think,
and neighbors were afraid of
neighbors and everything else,
suddenly you're confronted
with this again.
What do you think about,
was it shocking to you
that in a place where freedom
is supposedly so important,
how quickly everyone,
quote, unquote, "behaved"?
- Yeah, I think in the
name of public health,
how everybody just
lost any common sense,
any mind of their own.
But the thing is
the governments,
the mainstream media
was playing this fear
tactic to the people, right?
They were just saying how
as if the Covid is the deadly
virus and lying to people.
And so many childrens
that I had with my son,
their mothers would not let
their child out for two years
inside this like,
apartment condo.
Their child never seen
the sunlight in their life
for two years.
We don't even know
what that effects is
and how easily people
get brainwashed.
It's like North Korea,
during the BLM protest
and the looting,
my mother visited me in Chicago,
and we were just hearing these
guns shooting everything.
And then we turn on CNN and BBC
and all the mainstream media.
It says there was
really no violence.
It was mostly
peaceful protests.
- Mostly peaceful.
That's what they say.
- Yes, and then we could
not go buy the milk
because they were looting
the grocery stores literally,
that we could not
even buy the milk.
And the mainstream media
just lies to American people.
And if they were not
living in Chicago downtown,
they would not have known
what we went through.
- Yeah.
- And I would have believed
CNN if I were not
living in Chicago.
- Right, so you
eventually left Chicago
and made your way to New York.
New York's got its
own set of problems,
but it seems to be a little
bit better than Chicago, right,
in terms of that maybe?
- Yeah, a little better,
but as a Asian woman, there's
a huge hate Asian crime.
Like, literally whenever
I take the subway,
I know that I'm risking my
own life taking the subway.
And why is it so grimmer
is that when I was escaping
from North Korea and China,
I had at least a
place to escape to.
That was America.
There was a free country
there waiting for me.
I am scared every day for my
son because if America falls,
I cannot imagine the
world without America.
Where would my son
escape to for freedom?
There's no place left.
- Is there a weird thing sort
of psychologically for you
where when you were
escaping North Korea,
we've talked about
it in the past,
in some ways you didn't even
know what you were escaping
because you had lived in
that cave, so to speak.
So you didn't know what was
on the outside of that cave.
Here, where you see the
authoritarianism coming,
you didn't expect it here,
so I would imagine
in a weird way,
it's almost worse
seeing it here?
- It's a lot hopeless.
You know, it's a,
'cause now, I see the
map of the world, right?
In North Korea, I did
not see map of the world.
I did not know
what was possible.
Now, in the world,
I see the internet,
seeing all the human
history and Korea and world,
I know what's possible.
And America is the best chance
we've ever got as a humanity.
This is a humanities hope.
This is the best country
in human entire history.
And if people cannot
be happy in America
and refuse to defend this
country and individual liberty,
I mean, there's nothing in the
world that is left to defend.
I mean, the only thing that
is left is evil dictatorships.
So that's why I'm so heartbroke.
- So you write about this,
but what do you think
it is that we can do
to sort of ignite
that fire in people?
I mean, you know,
obviously everyone knows,
in Florida where you just were,
and you're coming
back pretty soon.
I mean, it's here.
There is this sense
of let's fight for it.
But we are losing a lot of
the states at the moment.
- I think for the
people to realizing
that this is America's,
our moment of cultural
revolution is happening.
This is a silent revolution
in happening classrooms,
in corporate businesses,
in the media.
It's happening everywhere,
and we just don't see it,
and media is lying to us.
They are changing entire
dynamic of this country
where somehow hate
speech is a violence,
therefore, you have no
right to speak your mind.
And that's not the
definition of freedom.
People don't even understand
what it means to be American,
and they're Americans.
Like, I became a
citizen last year,
and in my citizens test,
my interviewer asking me,
"Have you ever
persecuted anybody
for their political opinion?"
If I said yes, I could
not become American.
And that's what Google does,
that's what Facebook
does, what Instagram does,
and that what used
to Twitter did.
So these people have no idea
what it means to be American.
They are there running
these institutions
and brainwashing all of
us to believe that some,
this authoritarian
rule is somehow better.
So I think that
revolution really starts
with individual liberty,
individual responsibility
that we need to fight for
our children's education.
We need to, you know, start
going to city hall meetings
and show up and
demand what we deserve
and what free countries
should look like.
- How much of this do you think
is being directed by China?
That they just have so much
influence in our tech companies
and now in our government,
and, you know, that
we know for a fact
that Eric Swalwell
has had a relationship
with a Chinese spy,
and nobody does
anything about it.
He's still in Congress.
I mean, is this really just
coming directly from China,
just having us
silence ourselves?
Pretty easy.
Easier than invading us.
- I mean, they're,
this hijacking by
the CCP everywhere
is how Colombia gets money,
MIT gets money, right?
The big media gets money.
Not only that,
but when my first book was
trying to become a movie,
the producer sent me a script.
And the script is that
China was my promised land.
I was rescued by
Chinese authority,
and they gave me refuge.
I called the producer like,
"What are you talking about?
This is not what happened.
I was a sex slave at 13."
And he said,
"This is the only way
we can make a movie
in current Hollywood."
- [Dave] Wow.
- And that's when I realized,
even Hollywood, even just
pure entertainment is gone.
So we cannot even fathom how
much is hijacked by China,
and just for
instance, education.
I mean, healthcare, the media,
everything is under
Chinese control right now.
And I don't think a lot
of people understand
the gravity of this, you know,
problem that we are facing.
- What do we do to
wake people up to that?
I mean, they hear that
sort of thing a lot, right?
More and more of us
are talking about it.
But, you know, it seems
like it's like, just,
we can't barely deal
with our own government,
much less we have
to deal with China.
- I think it's a first
thing that we realize.
We still have time to go back
to the glory of this country.
When people meet me,
the first thing they
usually asking me like,
"Are North Koreans dumb?
Like, why there's no revolution?
They can just easily
start revolution.
Why you guys are putting up
with this totalitarian regime?"
And if you stand
up in North Korea,
not only you get executed,
the three to eight generations
of your family get executed.
And they do, and they
get all get killed.
In America, we are
currently don't get executed
for saying the wrong thing.
Maybe we get censored,
we called a racist and bigot,
and we lose our job,
we lose our dignity.
But we still, the
consequence of standing up
is not that as high compared
to North Korea and China.
So I think for us to realize
that even though there's
a price to be paid
to be free and
speaking your mind,
I think all of us now do not
propagate this PC culture.
And in classrooms,
at work, everywhere,
we need to speak our mind,
and we have to
think for ourselves.
- Can you talk a little bit
about how this has sort of
affected you politically?
Because, you know, we're
pretty good friends actually.
We've had many,
many meals together
and shot basketball together
and done a bunch of stuff.
But I'm not that familiar
with all of your politics,
but I'm only asking
actually because
it seems to me
you're being embraced
by people sort of on the right
and being neglected
by people on the left,
even though the
lefties would say,
"Hey, we're the ones
for human rights
and all of those things."
Yet, in your story, that's
not how this is playing out.
- Yeah, I mean when
it comes to left,
their human rights means
fighting for free healthcare
and free education.
That is a insult
to human rights.
Human rights means
like, right to liberty,
you know, right to happiness
and pursue your life.
But for them, it's all about
free stuff from government.
And their human rights
means, you know,
fighting for their
10,000 different genders
they come up with every day.
That's what they say is in
the name of human rights,
and why they are fighting
for those causes.
And that's when I
got disillusioned.
These people don't
even understand what
human rights means.
And using that slogan
every single day,
how talking about women's
rights is a human rights.
And then for them, what does
it mean, human women's rights?
It's like we have a right
to cry in the boardrooms
and we should feel
comfortable with that.
I'm like, do you know
there are people,
actual women are being
sold like livestocks?
They don't understand what
actual human rights means
in the real world.
And then the reason I became,
they say I'm a conservative.
I'm like, I was learning
that from reading your book,
the first of book, "Don't
Burn This Book", right?
Like what it means to
be a classic liberal.
That's who I am.
Like I,
I mean, you are gay, right?
Like, I'm friends with
so many gay people too.
And I just live in individual
liberty and let them decide,
and governments
should not have power
over what people should
do and what they think.
But believing that somehow I'm
a far right wing currently,
and it seems that most
people within a common sense
coming to the right camp
because you are the most
tolerant camp currently.
And I think I fed into that
because they accept me.
They don't say, "You've
been on New York Times,
therefore, you have no
right to speak your mind."
When I go to New York Times,
they said that, "You've been
on Fox, we cannot have you."
And recently, my book
just got published
with the same media
of Greta Thunberg.
I sold way more books than her,
and her book is a New
Times bestselling list,
and my book is not.
It happened with the first book,
and it happened Jordan
Peterson, and we expected that.
Right?
- Yeah.
You're you're in good
company my friend.
For the record, it did
happen to my second book.
We should've been number
two in terms of sales.
They didn't even put us on.
You know, I realized,
I mentioned,
I sort of half
threw away a comment
that we played
basketball together.
I'm gonna have them,
I'm gonna have my guys put
the picture of Enes Kanter
picking you up,
and you getting your
first alley-oop was
a pretty beautiful,
a beautiful,
a beautiful, beautiful moment.
But okay, so you're sort
of outside of the machine
because your story doesn't
fit their narrative.
Have you found any
ways of making inroads
with these people?
That seems to be the new thing,
that if there's some way
we can save some of them
and show them no, you
should be about human rights
before women's rights
or whatever it might be,
that that's the group of people
we wanna bring
with us right now?
- Yeah, I think that's
the hope, right?
There are so many people
that we can still save,
and they can still have
some kind of logic in them
that they can believe
that this is not,
this is wrong.
But in my book, I was
writing about how I was
invited by Jeff Bezos
to go to this like, private
gathering of American
greatest and movers and shakers.
And he flew me on the same
private jet of Harvey Weinstein
right before the Me Too.
And then at that Harvey,
I mean Jeff's event,
he gave a speech, and
everybody stood up
and giving him like,
standing ovation.
And the woman who accused
him in the Me Too,
she was in the seating too
and then calling him
the man and the legend.
Once the Me Too blows
up, I call them like,
"Did you guys know that he
was actually harassing women?"
Like, "Of course, we all knew."
Like, "Did you not know?"
The hypocrisy.
They only talk about women's
rights and Black Lives Matter
when it's convenient.
When there's actual
consequences of standing up for
like dignity and freedom,
they don't do that.
And one that I was invited to
by Tina Brown, by Daily Beast,
she invited me to join
this private gathering
with Nancy Pelosi.
And then she was
staying in this private
off the, you know,
record dinner.
She was saying she's
going to impeach Trump
tomorrow morning.
Like, and then she
was telling everybody,
"You know what to do."
And they're all these business
tycoons and finance people
at the same regions
all in downtown,
in midtown New York City.
And that means you
need to show the market
because market's gonna go down.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- Right?
If she's announcing
it tomorrow morning.
And at the time, I was
married to a trader,
I texted him like,
she's not like,
you know, impeaching Trump.
Like is this even legal?
Isn't that insider
trading information?
He's like, "Yeah,
that's illegal."
And that's when I
understood the corruption.
These people are not saying,
they are not misled.
They know what they are doing.
They're using this
ideology to control people
and better like, their position
and gaining more power.
And that's when I got
really disillusioned
of the hypocrisy
of American elite.
They don't care about anything
else other than themselves.
- Do you think we're just
kinda fat on our freedoms
that you can, you know,
wave the flag here?
You can ring the bell,
you can do a dance and try to
get everybody to pay attention
as many of us do.
But that Americans, we just,
we've all got the iPhone.
They've got the, you
know, PlayStation five
and whatever else
is distracting them.
And that really is the
reason that not enough people
will ever step up
until it's too late.
- Yeah, that's the thing.
There's TikTok, right?
There's a social media
platforms and all this Netflix,
everything distracting us.
We're so busy getting
entertained by this empty stuff.
And that is very
toxic a lot of times,
and people have
stopped reading books.
They have stopped understanding
what the meaning
of enlightenment
and what it means
to be individual.
So I think the problem
is a lot bigger
than I think what
I see currently.
And raising a child,
like it's really scary thing
right now currently in America.
And I think that's why I send
my child now Catholic school
and sending him to church.
I think at some
point it's beyond us.
And one thing that I know,
whenever there is a
communist revolution,
the first thing they do
is going after religion.
And that is very scary right now
how much religion is
getting attacked in America
and the people have no,
like if you are
somehow Christian,
you are like, being bullied,
that you're a stupid bigot.
And in North Korea, I know,
they killed God, and
they became God, right?
And they became
the most evil God.
So, yeah, I mean
at the end of day,
I just do everything
I can do in my power
and just have to pray.
- Yeah, I wanna back up
to what you said earlier
about living in New York
City as an Asian woman.
Obviously, I don't wanna
play identity politics,
but there really is a rash of
violence against Asian people.
Even when I was there last week,
there was a story about
an Asian woman just being,
you know, basically
malled on the subway.
Random guy, no purpose,
didn't steal anything,
literal just violence
for the sake of violence.
How concerned are you,
and do you feel like
anyone in New York
is gonna do anything about it?
- So it happened to
me several times.
Some guys come up
and just hug me.
And I'm just so like,
you know, freaked out.
Like, I don't even
know what to say.
I don't even know what if
they could just stab me
and shoot me, right?
Like, these people are not even,
I don't think even they're in
their sane mind at this point.
Everybody's on their fentanyl,
and drugs are everywhere.
Like, I used to
live in Manhattan,
now, I just moved out to Queens.
The K-Town is 32nd Broadway.
It's the most like,
Asian community.
We don't have drugs there.
Now, there are the
drug lords sending,
selling these like,
drugs in the purple wrap.
Looks like a lollipop.
And my son thinks
it's a lollipop.
He ask me to buy him that.
And that's a drug.
And there's a cop standing there
doing nothing about it, right?
They're just standing
there doing nothing.
And I think this is why
I'm just so curious
why Americans are okay
with their country's
being ruined.
And somehow, there's so
much resentment to America
in their mind,
in their mind that
America deserve
to get dismantled and destroyed.
And maybe that's why
they're not doing anything.
Because if you are,
if you love your country,
in any little passive way,
you cannot be sitting there
and your heart is not broke.
- Yeah, and then
at the same time,
they'll gladly take
someone like you
and throw you under the bus
as you fight to give
them the freedoms
that they're, you know,
in essence squandering.
Do you find that some of
the allies should do more?
I mean, what else should
guys like me be doing
and the people that you
are able to connect with
and talk to,
what should we be
doing to keep fighting?
- No, I'm eternally grateful.
When I was getting shadow
banned and censored everywhere,
the locals gave me
community, right?
I mean, now, Twitter got freed.
But I mean, you
guys did that before
where like, we had no place
to go speak our minds.
And it was so,
in a way, so oppressive,
like, you know,
country you expected
to have a freedom of
choice and voices,
and we didn't have that.
So I think people like
you being entrepreneurs
and finding opportunities
to give people freedom
and make things better,
I think that's very important.
So thank you so much
for the lockers.
- Trying, trying, you know.
(Dave and Yeonmi laugh)
I mean, thank you,
more importantly,
for everything you're doing.
What else is in the book that
people may not know about
either your story or what
you're fighting for right now?
- Yeah, I think that's where
people really need
to understand.
You know, it's not like I
came to America with agenda.
I didn't know what
left or right meant.
That's like, you know,
I did not even know what
Americas looked like.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- So coming here,
I was in the arms of the like,
really liberal left, right?
Penguin giving me training say,
"Don't ever talk
about what you think
about Second Amendments."
Because somebody was asking
me when I came to America,
"What do you think about
people owning guns?"
And I was like, "That's
a fantastic thing."
Because imagine if
North Koreans had guns,
I was not going to let them
take my father like that.
We are not gonna let them kill
our eight generations of family.
When you die anyway, you're
gonna fight to your death.
There's no country can
be ever be that enslaved
when they have guns to
defend their rights.
And even communism in Cambodia,
that before the genocide,
the first thing they did
was taking all the guns
from the people.
So my desire for owning that gun
is a lot deeper than just like,
some school shootings, right?
It's not about that.
And people were like,
"Just don't ever, ever
say that in public."
And they were like,
"What do you like?"
I said, "I like to read."
And they go, "What
do you like to read?"
I was like, "I love to
read Bastiat's, 'The Law',
John Stuart Mill, 'On Liberty'."
And they were like--
- I could see where
this is going, yeah.
- Yeah, just don't say that.
And back then, I did
not even know why
was not allowed to say that.
And because Penguin I
guess wanted to protect me
before I get branded left.
They just didn't
want me to do that.
And they would keep
begging me to write about
how hard it is to be a woman.
You know, how oppressed
as a woman living life
and how America is so
oppressed to the black men,
putting them in the camps,
which is like, same thing
we did to North Korean
like political prison camp.
I'm like, that's not even
the same thing, right?
If you go to political
prison camp in North Korea,
you don't make it even
until three months.
These people keep going
and keep coming back out,
and that's a problem.
So I think that's the
people don't understand,
like, I was not some
like, trained by CIA
and giving these messages.
I was a pure just
person coming here
and seeing the tendencies that
I was seeing in North Korea
happening in America.
And it's coming from a,
I don't know, it's a
really genuine place.
Like, people don't
recognize this pattern
because they never
seen a true oppression.
And I see the same
pattern and tactics,
and there is something called
"The Dictator's
Handbook", right?
And I feel like that's what
America's doing right now.
They're going through
this manual handbook
into how to control
full citizens.
And they're playing all the
tactics coming from every angle.
- Are you hopeful?
I mean, despite everything
you're describing here
and a sort of shock
to coming to America
and seeing a, you know, you
came in a time when it was,
we were in this
kind of upheaval,
but are you hopeful that we
can do the right thing here?
- Yeah, if we have,
if we do fight for
our Second Amendment,
I think we are never
gonna be the state
of North Korea and
China, that's for sure.
But I don't even know how
many generation can stand,
understanding the
meaning of self-defense.
You know, they think some,
our government's keep
brainwashing them.
The guns are bad, and there
are school shootings, right?
That's the brainwashing
you keep going through.
And eventually,
what's a narration,
they're gonna stop understanding
the meaning of having a gun
and give that up.
And that, I don't know.
So that's the thing.
Like, other than being
pessimistic, optimistic,
that's really irrelevant.
I know what's the
right thing to do.
I know it's my
responsibility as a mother
to tell my son what I know
about the world, right?
That's our responsibility
being adult,
educating our children about
the things that we understand,
so they can go further
understanding new things.
But we have been
failing at that.
We've been failing our children
and not teaching them the
things that we understand.
And I think that's why coming
from this new generation,
believing that they're
oppressed living in America,
and they wanna destroy
this country because,
you know, this
country's bigoted,
and they just heard that
from their teachers.
It's nothing about
based in actual truth.
- I was gonna ask you to
sum this all up nicely,
but I don't know that you can
do it any better than that.
Do you have any final thoughts?
- No, I mean,
that's all, I think.
You know, we just have
to do the right things.
Nothing about being hopeful,
being, you know,
like anything about.
Just do the right thing,
and that is telling the truth
and speaking up against power.
- The book is "What
Time Remains",
which is just a perfect title
too because there's urgency.
There's urgency, because
before you know it, it's gone.
Yeonmi, I look
forward to seeing you
in the free state of
Florida sometime soon.
- Yes, see you soon.
(soft music)
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about international issues,
check out our
international playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlist,
all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.